in Denmark Minnie has unveiled the
revised version of the countryman four
years after its launch the new version
is not only impressive in city traffic
but also off the beaten track the design
has been revised in numerous places
inside and out and fuel consumption and
exhaust emissions have been improved
the new countrymen now looks a bit more
grown-up and it has indeed grown bigger
without losing its poor round
versatility that's something that
appeals to women drivers in particular
we Nicholas no minister our tester
pinehold Eisenhower says the new
countryman shows that mini can now also
be maxing it's more than 4 meters long
that's the size the inventor of the
original Mini Sir Alec Issigonis
would never have dreamed of the original
Mini was just 3 metres long the new
countryman has a steeper grille and mini
says it's sporty ER and more efficient
so let's find out what that means is
that there are seven different engines
to choose from if we include the
four-wheel drive versions there are a
whopping 11 variants output extends from
72 kilowatts in the mini one countryman
up to 160 kilowatts in the sporty top
version Mini John Cooper Works
countryman we're testing the Cooper S
version with all-wheel drive and 140
kilowatts my nod says it's no surprise
the new countryman doesn't handle
exactly like the original Mini which
weighed 600 kilograms this is twice as
heavy but it's roomy space for five and
it's available with all-wheel drive the
all four which combines all-wheel drive
with a 140 kilowatt cooper s engine can
really move pretty
the 1.6 liter inline four-cylinder
gasoline engine with twin scroll turbo
delivers 240 Newton meters of torque our
test model reached 100 km/h in 7.7
seconds it tops out at 215 kilometers
per hour
you
dunno MINI Countryman is our tester says
the MINI Countryman offers style and
more space there's nothing else in this
class that has a combination of four
doors five seats and all-wheel drive and
is also a new color jungle green
Avant Galindo hunter changhie green the
upright front looks a bit retro and
emphasizes the Countryman's robustness
and versatility there are plenty of
individualization options such as
contrasting colours for the roof and
exterior mirror caps visually emphasized
underbody guards on the sides and front
and rear aprons are now standard
equipment in the all-wheel drive
versions the countryman we tested has a
ground clearance of thirteen point five
centimeters but that's only 11
millimeters more than the normal mini
other off-roaders offer a much higher
stance
the interior of the MINI Countryman has
a familiar look there have been no
experiments here instead there's been
lots of attention to even small details
in this five seater four is the magic
number as Mini CEO Peter Schwartz and
Bower explains I fear speed he says the
number four plays a very important role
because the countryman was introduced
four years ago it's about four meters
long and it has four doors and
four-wheel drive mini sold around a
hundred thousand countryman vehicles
annually so far which the CEO describes
as a massive success
with a base price of twenty thousand
four hundred euros the MINI Countryman
is 200 euros cheaper than the five-door
standard mini in Germany whether it's
really such a great off-roader is
debatable but when it comes to all-round
usefulness the countryman has a top of
his class
you